yes at the venetian earlier in the show
and now she's saying i do rocky is live
at the popular proposal and wedding
destination to see what they have in
store for tomorrow's big palindrome day
hi rocky
hey yes i said yes earlier at my
proposal and i'm saying i do i could i
imagine being dressed a little
differently for my big day but at least
i'm wearing white right that works and
you're certainly dressed for the
occasion so tina we're talking weddings
here at the venetian before the big day
tomorrow yes what is in store for you
guys as a team is this like a high
intensity day for you guys
paleotropic day actually the remainder
of february is all about that but
tomorrow's unique it is 2 2 2 2 right on
a tuesday exactly so we have a full
lineup of weddings and proposals on tap
for tomorrow because we are the property
of romance so
whether it be the gondola here we have a
tradition that is the star of the shot
everybody obviously you know the gondola
that you can ride here at the venetian
but there is a specific one for weddings
that is correct just exclusively for our
weddings we do have a wedding chapel as
well as a garden that weddings can take
place there also but as i mentioned to
you
we have nothing on plymouth wow if you
can imagine it whether it be the bridge
the front of the property in the lobby
we can create that for you with our
celebration specialist that is amazing
that is amazing so if people want the
quintessential vegas wedding they could
come here too absolutely can we call it
an elvis
uh we certainly can arrange to have an
elvis president absolutely we've done
that also
whatever you need to do here and for
tomorrow you know just give some people
some inspiration you know if they're
thinking about proposing if they're
ready for that big day
just give them some inspiration from the
professionals well here obviously you
know we have many opportunities for
individuals to do a proposal and to do a
wedding right if you were to call us
today we'll be able to arrange something
here on our property for you okay i
mentioned that because you can jump on
to www.venetianlasvegas.com
click on celebrations tab you'll be
immediately directed to one of our
celebration specialists and they'll be
able to work with you even as soon as
tomorrow we'll be able to work something
out for you because that's what we do
here at the venetian wow okay so the
inspiration is you have help
everybody we're here you're ready to
celebrate love tomorrow on two two two
two two and you know if you're not ready
to say yes or say i do tomorrow you can
just come here and hopefully hang out
and meet somebody
that's an idea for the single people out
there absolutely we have venues for
themselves
just hang out and love love will find
you yes write the gondolas around love
we'll find you thank you so much rocky